[Musique]
démonstrations de danses et cocktails à
gogo le tout dans une ambiance de soirée
les créateurs de l'application wii
sports n'ont pas fait les choses à
moitié pour son lancement ce samedi 15
avril et les guérés l'un des fondateurs
de l'entreprise explique son
fonctionnement
c'est une application mobile qui me
permettrait de trouver un partenaire
sportif et malheureusement je n'ai rien
trouvé
et c'est de ce moment là je me suis dit
je vais créer applications sportives tu
vas me permettent de trouver un
partenaire sportif autour de moi à côté
de chez moi qu'on pratique et peu
importe le sport que je veux dans un
premier temps wii sports sera testé en
ile de france et proposera tous les
types de sports pour lesquels il y aura
des recherches de partenaires ce soir là
toute l'assemblée à télécharger de
l'apli même commencé à l'utiliser
mon téléphone vers l'emploi
je crois que demain je le suivais pour
france bordeaux demain il ya d'une
course à 16h d'ailleurs son usage reste
gratuit pour les particuliers en
revanche côté professionnel du sport il
faut conclure un partenariat avec
l'application pour pouvoir y figurer
salle de sport associations et clubs
sportifs sont intéressés chez cap forme
on recherche beaucoup les des
particuliers comme ça qu'ils nous aident
à justement avoir à plus de clients chez
nous donc ça peut nous rapporter
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de potentiel
cinq jours après son lancement en grande
pompe on retrouve le cofondateur de la
société yannick guéret pour une partie
de wii sports organisés sur un terrain
multisports à guyancourt l'heure de
tirer un premier bilan d premier jour de
l'application
on a eu déjà plus de 200 t chargement
tout sur android 2 et sur ios d'accord
voilà exactement c'est ce que j'avais
prévu
pour l'instant c'est que la tranche
d'âge et entre 15 34 ans
pour une première phase ensuite bien
évidemment on compte toucher des
personnes un peu plus âgés on va dire
magnifique c'est j'attendais pas mieux
ça comment super bien l'entrepreneur vis
dix mille utilisateurs d'ici à trois
mois dans le département mais aussi
ailleurs en france